JON YOUSHAEI: So thank
you guys for joining us.
We're here at the Distribute
space in the YouTube studio.
And we're so excited
to be joined here
by the founder of Startup
Grind, Derek Anderson.
Derek, thanks so
much for joining us.
DEREK ANDERSON:
Thanks for having me.
JON YOUSHAEI: Awesome.
So just to get a little bit of a
preview of what to expect here,
we'll be talking
about distribution.
So the I/O space here's
divided into three main areas.
We've got Design,
Develop, and Distribute.
And we're here just to
answer one simple question
and get into it.
Once you have a
great product, what
do you do with it
to get it out there?
How do you distribute it?
And how do you make sure
people know about it?
And truthfully, I couldn't
think of a better person
to talk to about
this than Derek, who
has created something really
special with Startup Grind.
So why don't you go
ahead and talk about it.
And we'll dive into
all the details.
DEREK ANDERSON:
Yeah, Startup Grind
is a community of entrepreneurs
trying to educate and connect
founders across the world.
So we have local events that
we hold in about 100 cities.
Our whole program
is actually powered
by Google for Entrepreneurs.
And we have about 300
volunteers around the world that
help us run our events and
help build our community
and just help entrepreneurs.
JON YOUSHAEI: And
take me through,
Derek, for anybody who hasn't
been to a Startup Grind event.
Take me through what
exactly happens.
I walk in through the door.
And then what?
What should I expect?
DEREK ANDERSON: The first thing
we do is we give you a watch.
It's something we give
out at all of our events--
JON YOUSHAEI: I
thought you were going
to say you were
going to give me one.
DEREK ANDERSON: --tablets,
shwag, lots of shirts,
a lot of stickers.
JON YOUSHAEI:
That's all you get.
DEREK ANDERSON: Just like this.
It's exactly like this.
Now, so we host
really well-known,
legendary founders
and entrepreneurs
and venture capitalists.
We hear their stories.
We have them tell us about
the mistakes they've made
and the things that
they've done right.
And that's part of the event.
And then the other
part is really
trying to help you make friends.
So Startup Grind's
values are really simple.
It's about giving
more than you take.
It's about helping others
before you help yourself.
And it's about making friends.
You don't win an
award at Startup Grind
for getting the most
LinkedIn connections.
There's no award for the person
with the most business cards.
It's just, who can you help?
And what can you do for the
person sitting next to you
in a two or three
hour time period?
JON YOUSHAEI: That's awesome.
And any stories of people
who have met at Startup Grind
events that have gone to
develop products together?
Or--
DEREK ANDERSON: Yeah.
Well, actually-- so we started
hosting events in my office
with a room of about
this many people.
And one of the first
events, I actually
met a group of developers who
had just started an agency.
And we ended up working
together for the next two years.
We ended up doing all of
our business together,
was working together.
And we had met at
a Startup Grind.
We've had entrepreneurs
raise funding from speakers.
We've had entrepreneurs,
obviously, join together
and found teams together.
And then our community
of 300 people
who are really engaged
with each other-- and we
have very successful people
and people just starting out.
And we host the events in
every city in the world.
So if we don't have
Startup Grind in your city,
then email me at
derek@startupgrind.com.
Let's do it.
But those people are
constantly working together.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's fantastic.
So a big reason why I'm
so excited to have you
is not just to hear about all
your experience with them.
Because I feel you've spoken
to so many entrepreneurs
that you know about
how they've gotten
their products out there, how
they've shared their message,
and how they've gotten
users to sign up.
So what's an example of a
startup that you're really
inspired by that you think has
done a good job of distributing
their product?
DEREK ANDERSON: I think I
love the story of Pinterest.
Ben Silbermann told this
story about two years ago
where when they
launched the company,
it was basically like
every other startup--
like every startup
I've ever started,
anyways-- that
when they launched,
that it got so few users
that they were in stealth.
They didn't mean
to be in stealth.
But it just was.
And really no one
cared about it.
And the first month,
they had 100 users.
And then the second
month, they had 200 users.
And the third month,
they had 400 users.
And you think, well, that's
not growing very fast.
But they doubled every
month for 18 months.
And if you do the math,
by the 18th month,
you're at about 500,000 users.
And they've continued
to just grow
in that kind of
exponential growth.
And some of the early
things that they did
were they seeded it a little
bit non-traditionally.
They were based in Palo Alto
to start, at Silicon Valley.
But they went to two
mommy blogger communities.
They went to Iowa, which
is where Ben was from.
And so he had a community there.
He had connections there.
They seeded it with
female bloggers.
And then they went
to Utah, which
has this big female blogging
contingency, as well.
And he spoke at blogging
conventions and conferences
and met with these people.
And you don't hear about
many high-tech Silicon Valley
companies going to
Utah and going to Iowa
to find early adopters
for their product.
JON YOUSHAEI: Yeah, and really
interact with their users
from the onset--
and so can you talk
about how moving
away from the stories
of other entrepreneurs--
so take me
through Startup Grind Day One.
You said it started off
as a very small group.
How did it expand?
And did it start out
as your main thing?
Did it start out
as a side project?
Tell us everything about
how it got off the ground.
DEREK ANDERSON: Yeah, so I
worked at Electronic Arts.
I quit my job, started
building products, and failing
more and more spectacularly
every six months.
And while I was doing
that, a friend and I
started hosting these events.
And there wasn't
really anything to it.
It was just us getting together
and helping each other.
But after a year
and a half, we were
getting 250 people
coming every month,
and really with no effort.
All of our effort
was in the companies
we were trying to run.
And what had started
to happen was
I'd start have people
attending that would say, hey,
can I do this in my city?
And I thought that
was a horrible idea.
But I said, we have
nothing to lose.
There's nothing here.
It's just this thing that
we don't really care about.
But it seems to help
a lot of people.
So just do it.
And hopefully we won't
get sued or something.
And what ended up happening
was it worked in L.A.
It worked in New York.
And a couple of the things
that we did very early in terms
of distribution-- today, we
get about 100 inbound requests
a month to start new chapters.
In the beginning, no one cared.
And so honestly, we
would do anything
that we could possibly do
to start a new chapter.
Since Silicon Valley
is positioned as
like the melting
pot of the startup
world, every event that
we have in Silicon Valley,
about half the audience
is from somewhere other
than Silicon Valley.
And so we'd start to
pull from those people
and say, well, look
if you're here,
you've seen the experience.
You hopefully enjoyed it.
You should do this in your city.
And the first 20 chapters,
it was me finding people
at our events and
me convincing them
that this was a good idea for
them to spend their time doing.
There was no reason to do it.
We have someone here
today who started
our-- Brian Park has
started our DC chapter.
And I met him at my event.
I then saw him at
TechCrunch a few days later.
I literally begged him.
He was a good person.
He had the same values as me.
He was really passionate
about helping entrepreneurs.
I said, please, you
have to do this.
This will help you.
And he did it.
And he, in the
last two years, has
built an amazing community
in Washington DC.
But for the first 20
cities, it was really
blood, sweat, and tears,
begging, pleading, selling,
people on that this was
something good for them.
And we knew that it was.
But we had to convince them.
And once we hit 20
cities, the ball
started to roll to a
couple years later.
We only approve about 10%
of the inbound requests
for new chapters.
Used to be 100%.
We would approve anyone.
Anyone that would
touch it, we were in.
JON YOUSHAEI: And how do you
make that process so selective?
Or how do you go
about making sure
that the person who evangelizes
Startup Grind is the right
fit so you know that the
users that they bring on
are the right ones for
the Startup Grind values?
DEREK ANDERSON: Well,
like any good product,
you don't really know
what you're creating.
This was a big accident.
A lot of the best products
are just complete accidents.
And I don't know if we're in
the best product category.
But this was not the startup.
And so we tested.
Every new city we had was a
new Petri dish for us to test.
And we tried 100 different
things 100 different ways.
And then once we had all that
data across 10 or 15 cities,
we said, OK, here's
the road map.
We have what we can
kind of cookie-cut out
and replicate this
across the world.
And every six months, our
process completely changes.
So we've now been doing it
for about two years full-time.
And every couple of months,
we start all over again.
And how do we do this?
How do we look at this?
How do we organize it?
How are we going
to motivate people?
How are we going to
help entrepreneurs?
We rethink everything.
And that's just a
very iterative process
that most entrepreneurs probably
experience in their companies.
JON YOUSHAEI: Derek,
I love how you
call it an accident, the
start of Startup Grind.
And I want to talk about what
entrepreneurs or developers
here today can do to maybe
take an online presence
or an online app and move
it into the offline world
so you could have people connect
in real-time like you did
in just starting this
community as an offshoot
to the start of your work now.
What would you recommend
for people here today
who are developing
something and looking
to allow people to connect in
the real world in real-time?
DEREK ANDERSON: Well, if
you're not doing events,
you becoming the event
person is probably
not a good use of your time.
But there are a lot of
people doing things offline.
There are a lot of great events.
There are a lot of
great communities.
All those people want
to work with companies
that have the same
values as them
and have the same
mindset as them.
I think if you're
an entrepreneur,
it's so important to get your
product in people's hands,
to physically watch
them using your product.
Film it.
Talk to them.
And one thing that
I found is I've
had products that
were my babies.
And nothing could be
wrong with that child.
It had six toes.
But you'd better not
say anything about it.
It was bald.
But you know, it's beautiful.
It's the most amazing--
But with Startup Grind, for
me there's no personal agenda.
It's all, what do
the users want?
What do entrepreneurs want?
How can I help
entrepreneurs more?
And if that's something
completely different,
we'll do it.
And I think as you're
looking at, well,
how do we get it
into people's hands?
How do we talk to
people about it?
Look for companies.
Look for groups that, A, you
want to aspire to be like,
so people that make you
look better, but also
that you can add value to.
And that could be a sponsorship.
That could be a partnership.
That could be you bringing
your users to them.
But go look for people
that are like you and that
make you look better.
And then find ways to
make those people look
good through what you're doing.
And if you can look at,
what's in it for this person?
I know what's in it for me.
But what's in it for them?
And how can I make
them look good?
Then you may be able to do
some meaningful partnerships.
JON YOUSHAEI: So let's
talk a little bit more
about partnerships.
You've been able to put together
a terrific one with Google
for Entrepreneurs.
It's obviously taken a
long time to develop.
I know in catching
up the other day,
you were talking
about a partnership
that Electronics
Arts developed when
you were working in the
digital space over there.
Can you give a story about
how when an app was coming out
either that you were
working on or that you heard
about closely, how did they
distribute in their first days?
What partnerships did they get?
And how did they get
their app out there?
DEREK ANDERSON: So if you're
an early-stage startup,
you have nothing, a
lot of times, to give.
There's not a lot of
value that you have.
Because you have no users.
You have limited traction.
You have all these
things against you.
And so one thing that you can
do is look at other startups
who are in the same position.
And try to work with them.
And you want 1 plus 1
should always equal 5.
Or it's not worth doing.
And so if 1 plus 1 equals 1.5 or
1 plus 1 equals 2, keep moving.
Keep thinking.
Keep looking.
But one thing that-- this
was several years ago.
This was right when the Facebook
marketplace became available.
But this startup
emerged that was just
a kind of a toolbar at
the top of apps that
would market five or
10 different games.
And basically, all of
those startups would opt in
and say, yes, we will add
this toolbar to our app.
And then we'll all help each
other market our products.
You could say, well, they
compete with each other.
They compete for time.
But they weren't the same game.
But they were games.
And so they had the same
kind of customer base.
You later then saw people like
Zynga or EA or other people
create their own to cross
promote their own games.
But that was, to me,
a very innovative way
for startups to
help each other who
didn't have any
sort of distribution
or didn't have any traction.
When you start working with
bigger companies like a Google
or a Kauffman Foundation
or an Apple or a Facebook,
it's a different position.
Because you need
to make sure that,
again, you have
something to offer.
And so in our case with Google,
we had been going for two years
before we ever even approached
them-- 2 and 1/2 years.
And when we approached
them, we said, look,
we've done hundreds of events.
You're doing hundreds of events.
This can really add
to your mission.
And we're aligned in our
values and our goals.
And we said, we can add
this to what you're doing.
We know what Google
could add to us.
It's pretty obvious that
there's lots of great things
Google could do for us.
But what could we do for Google?
And we can't help Google a lot.
But we can do our own
little things and support.
And so that conversation
was much easier.
Because we were
thinking about them.
And they were thinking about us.
And then with that, you've
got to be thinking about,
do I have the time and energy
to fight this thing out?
And a deal with a big company
might take six months.
It might take nine months, even
if you look great from day one.
If you don't look
great, you might
be a year or year and a half.
And so you have to be ready to
last that full length of time
and to be able to patiently
wait for those people
to come around.
Or you might waste your time.
Or you might waste their time.
Or you might just run
out of juice on them.
JON YOUSHAEI: Yeah.
No, I love your note
about the patience
of working with big
partners, but also
the scrappiness of bringing
little partners together
and creating your own
distribution network.
I think so many
times with startups,
you think, oh, we don't
have the leverage.
There's all these
Goliaths our there.
And we're just a bunch of
Davids here who can't distribute
and partner to help one another.
But I think the example
you gave is beautiful
and that you can approach other
products, other developers
and try to cross promote
to help one another out.
So is there any other tips you
would give to an entrepreneur
starting at day one or anything
looking back at your career
as an entrepreneur?
Hey, I would do
this differently.
Or here's a specific
piece of advice
that I would give to a developer
who may have been in my shoes
a few years ago.
DEREK ANDERSON: Well, when
I started building products,
I wrongly just said
this is my vision.
I know that people want this.
I'm just going to build it.
And I think, as I
mentioned earlier,
getting customer feedback,
developing hand in hand
with users, with people that
actually need the product--
But then also, as you're
thinking about the product
and you're thinking
about your team,
are you also thinking about
your distribution strategy?
Do you have a
cohesive plan for, how
are we going to get to
a million page views?
Or how are we going to
get to 100 customers?
We just had this
great talk from Sean
from Tinder, who said the first
day when the product was ready,
he made everyone in the
room send a text message
to 100 people.
That's a very simple,
tangible thing they could do.
And then they went to colleges.
And they got the key
influencer at each college
and had them share
with all their friends.
That's a very simple,
easy way to grow
and to get to some
sort of critical mass.
JON YOUSHAEI: Totally.
DEREK ANDERSON: And
if you're a startup,
you don't need a lot of money.
You don't need to
spend on AdWords yet.
You just need to come up
with a simple, creative way
to get enough users
and customers to start
to get some traction and
show you have momentum.
And then if you do that,
everything else will follow.
Investors will follow.
Cash will follow.
Team will follow.
All these other
things will follow.
But if you have a great product,
which is pretty difficult,
and then on top of that, a
great distribution strategy,
then people might
actually see your product.
You might become noticeable.
You might get out there.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's awesome.
So I want to close
with one last question.
Then I want to open
it up to you guys
to be able to ask Derek any
questions about Startup Grind,
distribution, et cetera.
But Derek, as you
move into the future,
how do you view Startup
Grind's expansion and growth
on a global basis?
Your numbers are astonishing,
over 75,000 entrepreneurs
impacted at your events at over
100 cities across the globe.
How do you keep up
that growth rate?
And what are your plans for
the future to continue growing?
DEREK ANDERSON: Well, I
got some really good advice
from someone named
George Zachary, who
was one of the first investors
in Yammer and Twitter.
And he said, growth for
growth's sake is pointless.
And so for us, getting to 100
more cities or 1,000 cities,
what's the point?
I think for us, the question
that we ask ourselves
just about more
than anything else
is, how can we help
entrepreneurs more today
than we did yesterday?
And there are 400
million entrepreneurs.
So there's plenty to help.
We've helped 75,000.
That's like nothing.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's a
good way to look at it.
DEREK ANDERSON: So what can
we do to improve that help,
to scale up that help, to really
make entrepreneurs successful.
And that's what
we're trying to do.
So--
JON YOUSHAEI: Awesome.
So with that, we'll open it
up to Q&A from the audience.
If you guys have-- [INAUDIBLE]
We'll get you a mic.
AUDIENCE: What's your
monetization of Startup Grind?
Is it now or in the
future or a combination?
DEREK ANDERSON: Yeah.
So our monetization
model is very simple.
And it's that all of our
events are paid events.
And we have sponsors
and partners
that help support the events.
So we're not an incubator.
We're not an accelerator.
In a world where everybody
asks you to give them
a piece of your
company, our goal
is just to help and to support
and to give you connections
and give you education
and to do that
at a ticket price or
a sponsorship price.
So it's as simple as that.
AUDIENCE: Do you ask for
anything from the companies
that you help?
In the future once
they grow, do you
ask for a percentage of their
profits or anything like that?
DEREK ANDERSON: Will you give
us a percentage of your profits?
We will take them if
you'll give them to us.
We don't.
So it's kind of
[? this-- ?] I don't
know if it's revolutionary.
It just seemed like the
best thing to us to do.
But we support.
But we think
entrepreneurs should
control their own companies.
Most companies are
bootstrapped in the world,
not in Silicon
Valley, where we are.
But most entrepreneurs
bootstrap their companies.
They have to figure it out.
They have to get friends
and family to help them.
They have to save their money.
They have to live
in their garage
or their-- I was going to
say their mom's garage,
but live in their
apartment and work out
of their apartment for a long
time to get things going.
So we think entrepreneurs
should keep their equity
and should spend it
on getting great teams
and getting great
people involved in it.
And for us, it's about just
providing that education layer
and helping in that way.
AUDIENCE: So when did you decide
to leave your full-time job
at EA and then go into
Startup Grind full-time?
DEREK ANDERSON: So it kind
of took me about two years.
I'm married.
And I have an amazing wife.
But it took me two
years to convince her
that quitting my
job was a good idea.
And we did that six weeks after
we had our first son, which
is probably the worst time you
could possibly quit your job.
And then I built about five
or 10 different products
in the two years
before I started
working on Startup
Grind full-time.
So I did not quit
to do Startup Grind.
I quit to do a number
of other things
that you've never
heard of, and which
I hope you won't
dig up from my past.
But the Startup Grind,
it just was very natural.
It was very evolutionary.
And over two years,
it became the startup.
And so if you're going to
quit your job, save your money
and get your wife as your
co-founder, or your husband.
Because they're as important
as anything you do,
is getting your family
on-board that-- look,
this is going to
be a long journey.
This is going to be tough.
This isn't going to be stable
like what I've been doing.
You jump off the cliff and you
build a parachute on the way
down is a good
explanation of what
it felt like for me, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What are the bars for
opening a chapter?
For example, a
number of attendees,
something like that--
and how independent
are these new chapters?
Do they have freedoms
over sponsors
or accepting sponsors,
something like that?
DEREK ANDERSON: So
the bars for starting
a new chapter are you have
to put a plan together.
And the most important thing--
really, the only major bar
is that you have to share
the same values as us.
And so if you share those values
and we think you can actually
execute it, the size of
the city doesn't matter.
The country doesn't matter.
We do it in 42 countries.
We're going to have our first
even in Iran next month.
We're in Georgia.
We're in the Congo.
We're in Nairobi.
I just spoke with somebody
from our Nairobi chapter
that's here at Google
I/O. She was pretty cool.
So but it's just, do you
have the same mindset as us?
And can you lead a
community in a way
that we know it needs to
be led to be successful?
And what we've found is if
you get those people in place,
everything else just works out.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's awesome.
AUDIENCE: Two questions--
first, do you have competition?
And if so, what
does that look like?
And the other
question is that you
have insight into many,
many companies, obviously.
And I'm sure people
that you're connected
with throughout this Startup
Grind say, oh, I just
saw something
really great, or, I
know guys that are
looking for investment.
Do you partner with
venture capital groups?
Do you do your own investments?
And also, are you still
pursuing your own products?
You seem like an idea guy.
And do you see something
and go, oh, I can do it.
So 'a couple questions.
DEREK ANDERSON: OK.
So on the competition
front, there
are other great
events or communities
that sometimes compete
a little bit for time
with entrepreneurs.
But I wouldn't look at
them as competitive to us.
UP Global is a great example
of a great community that
helps entrepreneurs
all over the world.
They're kind of similar to us.
But we work together
and partner together.
Google for
Entrepreneurs does lots
of things for entrepreneur.
You could say, well,
that's kind of competitive.
But really, this
space is interesting,
because it's very
socially driven,
people that have a
social-driven purpose.
And so we're helping
100,000 entrepreneurs.
And if you're helping
a million, then great.
We're all just trying to help.
There are so many entrepreneurs.
So competition's maybe
not the right word.
But there are other
people that are
helping entrepreneurs
in great ways.
And then in terms of the--
what was the other question?
Oh, the VC's, yeah.
Yeah, so I am not an investor.
No, I am absolutely
not an investor.
I'm just an entrepreneur.
I hope I can be an
entrepreneur for 30 years.
There's this really what I think
is a negative trend of, when
I make it as an
entrepreneur, I'm
going to become an investor
so I can get more rich
and work less.
And I hope I always
am an entrepreneur.
I hope I always have the
energy to be an entrepreneur.
I'm not sure I will.
But I don't know
what else I'll do.
But hopefully I can last 30
years as an entrepreneur.
I can't lose any more hair.
So at least I know that.
And we do see great companies.
And we love to
just connect them.
We don't take a percentage.
We're not brokers.
We just try and support
great entrepreneurs.
And we don't introduce
everyone to everyone.
But when we see a great
company, we absolutely
will introduce some
of our speakers.
And for me, I do have
ideas on things to do.
But the purpose of, at least
for me of being an entrepreneur,
was always to find something
I could focus on and just do
full-heartedly.
So for several
years, it probably
looked like I was very
sporadic and scatter-brained.
And maybe some of you
are in this position.
Because you don't want
to put all your chips
on black on that one bet.
And so you spread a
little bit to make sure
you've got other doors.
But at some point, you've
got to put all your chips
on the table on the right bet.
And so for me, that
came about two years ago
with Startup Grind.
And we had three chapters.
It wasn't like, this is for
sure going to do something cool.
It was, this seems like
the right thing to do.
I'm finally going to
go all in on this.
I'd gone all in on other things.
But I'm just going
to go all in on this.
And I hope I do this
for a really long time.
I'm very focused on the
mission and the values
of what we're doing.
And so actually, I have ideas.
But I kind of suppress them.
Or I brainstorm
with entrepreneurs.
And that's a way for me to
be creative outside of just
being creative in
what we're doing.
JON YOUSHAEI: So
with that, I just
want to thank Derek
for your time.
Thank you so much.
DEREK ANDERSON: Great.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me.
JON YOUSHAEI: Thank
you very much.
DEREK ANDERSON:
Thank you. [APPLAUSE]
JON YOUSHAEI: Cool.